normally Cesar first consults with the
owners today it's the dogs that offer
some valuable insight from the second
the front door opens today I couldn't
use my normals how can I help you cuz
cuz we are gonna help them
can you ever stop no no you know this is
why I like to come to people's home and
evaluate how they behave how they react
and who they are and more importantly
what is it that their dogs tell me that
they are because that's really you know
the one who tell you right away if you
get nervous in a situation you know the
you not supposed to this is the vibe
that you're going to provide after a
little while she comes down so there's
new Reid you really never control the
behavior she just chose when to calm
down yeah and that's what they pick up
they pick up well he doesn't know and
he's worried about it but she's a
fearful dominant one yeah because you
have to protect somebody who who feels
he doesn't know how to do it and worries
about it yeah so this is who you are in
her world alright so how often do you
take your dog for a walk not nearly
enough all right so how are we gonna do
that
how do you learn gonna house just start
taking her more now right now what do
you want into that state right now what
I'll because you're just dominant over
me
no no no that was that's your conscious
self if he normally does it yeah well
like even in the show like the
characters that we do and portray on the
show is kind of like an exaggeration of
ourselves so my characters like more
focus and kind of like calm because I'm
like the big sister so I'm kind of like
that when he does his character is very
jittery friendly but kind of nervous
which is kind of like him and just an
exaggeration of himself
you can leave two lives I mean you can
have that as there almost no and then
you can have your chocolate yourself
which you you can only be common
assertive yeah that's the key is the
awareness what energy am i right now
mm-hmm that's the question that I would
like for you to start asking yourself as
soon as you punch out from from work